deserves half
you think so okay okay no I'm just
curious hands high hands high one he's
half no I'm gonna go I'm gonna do
different percentages so you say half
you say up 20 years half okay do you
think she deserves
um 30 percent
of your wealth
after 20 years and the people that
didn't say 50 30 if she deserved 20 20.
20 you give her 20. all right ten
percent does anyone think zero percent
okay does anyone think more than 50
percent
just I'm just curious my perspective is
a little bit different I mean like I am
I am married I didn't raise my hand
um I can't imagine oh I mean this is my
perspective so it's very subjective
um so I can't imagine any reason that I
would get divorced I think it would have
to come down to something that's
absolutely uncontrollable like there's
nothing that I could think about at this
point in time you know maybe maybe
there's uh an addiction or maybe you
know there could be the death of a child
sometimes you just can't come back from
that but my thing about it is is like if
I had to had to outside of Mega control
get divorced I feel like I could sit
down over breakfast and have a
conversation because the intent is that
you don't marry you know like an a-hole
right you sit down and you say look I
don't think this relationship is viable
uh can I get your help for the next
three to six months how much do you
think you could do this is when I expect
I can get a job I feel like you can
negotiate I think women are too too
quick to go to the court over things
that you can really settle down over
breakfast but I I think it's the women
typically that don't want to be the an
adult in that situation and I think that
that's wrong yeah I think if she spent a
certain amount of time with you and
she's invested in you in your growth now
that might not be like you mentioned
about the Jeff Bezos thing he had
nothing really until he didn't have what
when he married her he didn't have
nothing to a certain degree to what he's
got now right so she's she's factored
into that to some degree of success now
that might not be from a business aspect
but it's from some of the things we've
mentioned here today on the board you
know peace support etc etc and I feel
like that is not a reward but almost
like a a uh like maybe a payout or just
like a compensation to some degree but
she has to but this is this goes back to
our point before like this is why we
spend a lot of time vetting them to even
get the ring in the first place because
you want to feel like okay she's built
me up to a certain way where she yeah I
wouldn't feel too bad about giving her
half because she's been there from the
from the bottom and I'm like I'm a huge
believer in whatever you have before
marriage that's your that's his that's
hers I agree that that's what I believe
but whatever is after the marriage like
a decent and split but whatever's before
the marriage is is fully separate so
whatever happens beyond that I think
it's the first split all right um raise
of hands do you think men should page do
you think men should pay child support
yes yes if you think yes it depends on
the context so if I know all the money's
going to the children yeah okay so oh
interesting so you yeah you mentioned so
100 of men okay interesting but is that
what you're saying just there if I know
if it's going to I don't know then I'm
paying for child myself yeah I will pay
the child myself
a bit about the child I think women are
so so so dumb sometimes because like
let's say you had you had a cool baby
daddy right you guys were chilling
co-parenting whatever and then you got
this little little bug in your ear
talking about taking taking the child
support put him on child support you
know like that man might be offended and
give you less and he was already going
to be involved in the child because he
wants that kid but now you as the woman
you're gonna get 300 or 500 a month
you're stupid you could have been
getting like a couple Grand or if you
stayed in the relationship you could
have been getting all the resources but
uh yeah uh the married woman did not
raise her hand no child support for me
no yeah I just I just don't know why
we're paying girls to leave yeah like
that that's that's my my like that's the
way I think about it I'm like where why
does she get money I didn't get pregnant
yeah no money
I hear it it's not taking away
accountability but I think guys have
this innate like protection almost
towards women so I just think it's kind
of in guys I'd be more thinking about
the kids yeah you know how I think we
solve the child support um problem
men should just get custody of the
children yeah and that's how many of you
think that you think men should
automatically get custody of the
children I mean
statistics
depends on the age okay of the kids okay
because they actually improve yeah
statistically like they will keep the
sun's out of jail on there definitely
the girls the daughters of the stripper
pole I think that there's a time for mum
and there's a age for that why do you
say no
um I say no because I would imagine I'd
pick a good woman to look after my child
and I'd still be involved so my
involvement is going to steer them in
the right direction so okay I'm gonna
Read Super chats because I haven't read
them in the show sorry guys I see you
guys blowing up the chat guys make sure
you like the video um the like is the
most important metric that YouTube uses
there's almost 2 000 people in here so
there should be 2 000 likes on the video
make sure you hit that like button okay
um Swiss um if she's not an asset she's
a burden um Philip holy mackerel Pearl
and Ally back together again let's go
Casey after have you guys noticed how
peaceful and civilized Today's Show is
when it's a bunch of logical minded guys
and there's no emotional 304 is just
saying a 200 super chatter on news
Tyler Tyler zika I'm choosing choosing a
month total for specific relationship
Milestones as a Fool's errand chemistry
and commitment is all that matter
waiting to have sex before marriage no
no corn no Fab is the only way to show
someone you are serious about the
marriage else you are just exploiting
each other from the start Matt butcher
it's all often the women who have
totally unreal expectations and or
trying to change the man after the fact
or they are just evil to begin with
Mr Dill agath if a marriage breaks up
and the judge grants 50 50 to custody
then there shouldn't be any child
support payment if the marriage laws
didn't punish men women wouldn't break
up a marriage Dario Duplin I know I'm
late but my older brother took seven
years before he married his wife they've
been together for 15 years now Tales
from um settle Ranch and engagement time
shouldn't be infinite since no man in
the U.S should marry it exposes you to
the worst emotional and financial
disaster possible mgtow Doug MPA
feminism made it so men don't owe women
anything a man can take as long as he
wants to commit it's up to the woman to
leave if he's taking too long Matt
butcher a lady can easily put on an act
for six months to hook you when you
found out how psycho she is you will be
floored um amend Dana it if it takes
knowing all women to figure them out you
never will learn the one person you're
with and learn them just saying iconic
FPS men want someone to support them
would it not be relevant to lead by
example and remain monogamous for the
sake of leading by example Matt butcher
the multiple partners thing gets old and
is a lot to keep up with the best is one
partner and the best is one partner and
know how to get her to want sex Pearl
did you have trouble reading this LOL
shut up
um TJ Drummond 178 100 Super Chat thank
you Reginald Enterprises it's always the
top men but it was Men in your town now
that travel is easy it's it's become the
top men in the world 90 Frito pie
be righteous about saying no to sex
don't be Petty Matt Hugh I love your
message you're making change in here
healing the world speak we are listening
see Dumbledore if um guys either after
the wedding or after the first kid comes
it's all over dead bedroom is
practically guaranteed as many of you
have used just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible